here's another example not as dramatic
of creating a photo illustration out of
photographs but in this case this is
also showing evidence that you are
fabricating the pieces in your device
this particular image as a CAD image
used by the researchers to show their
device showing the various fabrications
and this is how they used it in their
patent submission but this is done in
CAD they also made a picture of their
device but you really can't see very
much about their very sophisticated
ability to make the various layers and
so what I did was I took that device and
separated into the initial pieces that
they did fabricate I laid them out on a
background and decided to try to use
these images showing the layering of how
the device is made so I out of these
images I constructed a photo
illustration of those pieces using
software but these are real images that
you've just seen from before here's
another way of showing it making it
somewhat three-dimensional but basically
this is a photo illustration of the
layers of this device not only showing
how it works with the right labeling of
course but also showing that they did
indeed fabricate the layers